Thank you and um thanks for inviting me.
Great to be here. Uh the usual
disclosure. So even though my company
name is on well will be on every slide
after this. Uh they're just sponsoring
me to be here. This is not an official
talk.
So
I have to say when AI came along I was
something of a skeptic. Okay. So I'm a
hardware hacker and I'm thinking
how can AI really help me with hardware
hacking. You know until like data can
come up and start plugging things in or
Captain Kirk can break my triorder and
put it back together and make it do
something. I don't get it. How's AI
going to help me?
Because for AI uh sorry for hardware
hacking you need a lab. Okay, you need
hardware, you need scopes, you need
components, you need um you know
electronics. Um this is a particularly
nice lab by the way. I wish I wish my
lab looked like this. This is actually
Joe Grand's lab. I don't know a lot of
you will have heard of him. Uh he's a
very talented hardware hacker. If this
talk in any way inspires you to do
hardware hacking, he gives really great
training courses. So, he's your man.
Look up Joe Grand. And as you can see,
his his lab is so nice, he has a
security guard to make sure it stays
that way, right? So, you go in there and
try and move a wire or something, that
guy's going to pounce on you. So,
back at my house,
it looks more like this. So, I mean,
obviously at work I have really, you
know, state-of-the-art labs and so on,
but this is my home uh hacking around
lab.
And yeah, you need tools, you need um
in this case FPGAs, you need uh
debuggers, you need power supplies, you
I've got a glitching platform there,
which is an EM pulse generator.
Um all kinds of crap that has to be
wired together. And so again, how the
hell can AI help me with that?
So what changed? How come I'm up here
talking about, you know, singing the
praises of AI if I'm such a skeptic and
AI can't help me?
So basically uh I was on a a business
trip and actually this is the setup from
when I went on that business trip and I
was trying to crack a specific target.
So the target is there sitting on the
the XY platform
and I've got scripts running that are
basically trying to glitch it. So people
are not familiar with glitching.
Glitching is a a technique where you
basically try and trick the chip into
doing something it's not supposed to do.
So in this case, I'm trying to dump the
firmware from that chip, but the chip is
locked. So to glitch it, you basically
say, right, at the moment it does the
check, this guy said, give me your
firmware. The chip says, am I allowed to
give the firmware? Is it locked? And you
hit it at that point. and try and
confuse it and it goes, "Okay, here's
here's my firmware even though it was
locked and it shouldn't have given it to
you." So anyway, I have scripts running.
It's a non-deterministic process. So you
may have to repeat your glitch, get the
timing right, get the the power of the
glitch right, and so on um hundreds,
thousands, maybe even millions of times.
So, I was on this business trip and I
left the scripts running and for 6 weeks
it was running 24/7 just banging away on
this chip trying to get it to give up
its firmware.
And it didn't. I got back from the trip.
6 weeks later, nothing. Script still
running. Zero results.
Now, in the meantime, um
there was a guy organizing an online
event
called Prompt or Get the [\h__\h] Out, which
was uh you can find it on YouTube. And
it's basically five minute talks about
AI and what you're doing with AI. And
I'm not going to say who he is because
he's kind of shy and retiring, but um
he said uh he kept saying to me, "When
are you going to come online and give
your talk?" And I'm like, "Gaddy, I
don't do AI, right?" Um all I use it for
is looking up data sheets, maybe take a
picture of a component and say, "What
the hell is this?" and let AI figure it
out for me. I'm not using it dayto-day.
I've got nothing to talk about.
So he said, [cough] "Excuse me." He
said,
"You're asking the wrong questions.
Just do me a favor.
Think of three questions that are
relevant, really relevant to what you're
trying to do and then ask AI.
Maybe it'll help."
So the three questions when you're
glitching
are where to glitch, when to glitch, and
how much to glitch. Those are the three
basic questions. So if we go back to my
setup here,
the where to glitch is in this case. Oh,
maybe I can get a mouse working. Hang
on.
Can you see my mouse pointer?
So the where is
the chip is quite big and this little
probe is quite small. So where do you
put the probe on the chip? The when to
glitch is you know how how many nanconds
or microsconds from a particular event
like a reset
um and how much is how many volts should
I give the EM pulse in this case.
So
I asked those three questions
and it gave me an answer. So for the for
the position I just went into chat GPT
online and I said I'm attacking this
chip. I didn't say attacking because if
you say attacking it'll say oh I can't
help you with that. That would be
naughty.
Um, so I just phrased it like if I
wanted to perform an EM pulse fault
injection on this model chip, where
would I put the probe?
And
when would I send the pulse and how hard
should I hit it?
So it said draw a diagonal line across
the chip and I forget the exact number
but put the probe 7 mil in from the
corner. So the diagonal line between two
corners put the probe 7 ms in
when uh it said basically
as soon as this happens. So on this
event send the the glitch and how hard
it gave me a process. It said um start
at 500 volts which is the maximum you
can give the chip shouter and when it's
crashing 50% of the time that's the
sweet spot then we'll start running.
Okay, great. So I set it all going. I
did the the 50% test. I figured out what
the voltage was. Set it going. Went
downstairs. Got myself a cup of coffee.
came back
and it was done.
7 minutes. 7 minutes. So, I'd spend six
weeks banging, well, not me, but my
Python that was banging its head against
a brick wall. 7 minutes.
So, it's like shock.
So now, yeah, I'm a believer. I believe
this [\h__\h] works. Okay, so what's next?
So what happens if I just say to Claude,
"Okay, don't give me instructions. I'm
You're not the boss of me. I'm the boss
of you. You do this stuff. Okay, I'm not
taking your advice and going and typing
stuff in. So here here's my lab. It's
yours now."
So in the lab we've got a debugger which
has S swd J tag. We've got a logic
analyzer which can sniff UART [\h__\h]
whatever. We've got the the glitch
trigger which in this picture
is this guy here which is an FPGA
um voltmeter scopes buarts whatever
power supply. So I gave that all to
Claude and said, "Do your thing."
[clears throat] And it gave me back
this.
And what this is is a Raspberry Pi Pico.
And it has all of those things in it.
So it talks direct to the target with
SWD or JTAG. So that's a couple of pins
kind of here somewhere.
Uh it sniffs UART SPI or ITC.
Um it does five nanocond resolution
timing for glitching.
It has uh peripheral control, so
eight hardware UARTs. And if you know
what a Pico is, you'll go, "Hang on a
minute. Pico's only got two hardware
UARTs."
Uh actually one of the joys of using
Claude to do all the donkey work is you
can have crazy ideas and say well I need
more than two UARTs. So how are we going
to fix that? And Claude will say well
each of those two UARTs has four
alternate pin configurations.
So why don't we just flip the configs?
you know, you wire up up to eight
devices and I'll just flip the configs
for you when you need to talk to that
device. And I'm like, genius. Okay, I
now have eight hardware.
Thanks, Claude.
So, yeah. Um,
that's what we did. And
now I can just think of crazy [\h__\h] and
say to Claude, "Hey, Claude, what if we
And this is a screenshot of a chat I was
having with a a work colleague where I'm
explaining this particular glitch to
him.
And in mid conversation with him, I'm
like, "Hang on a minute. Why are we
messing around with timing to try and
create a voltage drop to a particular
point? When we have an ADC on the pico,
we can just measure the voltage. And
when we reach that point,
so I I could use the ADC to measure the
timing to get to that voltage. And
actually Claude took it one step
further. I hope you couldn't read it
here,
but uh
Claude said, well, an alternative
approach would be
instead of just measuring, we could use
the ADC to actively control the timing.
So we're going to do the glitch. I'm not
going to give it any parameters. It's
going to measure the voltage on the
target and when we hit the right point,
then bam, it's going to do the glitch.
It's going to stop the glitch. Bring the
power back up.
So, I said to my colleague, "Hey, Claude
likes that idea."
So, Claude told me, "Connect one wire
and I'll take care of the rest." So, I
connected up the ADC. It wrote the code.
It ran it. I didn't even run it. I just
came back and I saw this string of this
is all FFS because it was a blank chip I
was testing. But it dumped it unlocked
and dumped the data on the first try.
And I'm like, "Holy fuck."
And that's my colleague laughing. Okay.
So,
what could possibly go wrong?
So, I have here,
the device in question.
So, the white board is the target, the
green board is the Pico,
and
Let's give it a go.
I don't know. Where are we?
Sorry, I need my glasses.
Uh, so just to prove this isn't a fix,
um, I'm using the official tool to talk
to the chip
and it's unlocked at the moment
completely blank.
So I am going to fill memory
with
someone give me a hex value.
boobies. Are we doing boobies then? Is
okay. I had two guesses what it was
going to be. It was going to be dead
beef or boobies. So, I guess we're doing
boobies.
Uh, actually, we need one more zero.
And then we say it like
Homer boobies.
Um it's little Indian so it looks a bit
weird. So I'm going to change the option
by
uh readout protection. I'm going to
protect it.
Apply.
So if I disconnect
and reconnect.
So data read failed. It can't read it
back because it's now locked. Okay. So
if I go to the read, there's no no data
to display.
So, let's leave this guy.
So, [clears throat] now I'm connected to
my Pico hacker
and it's [clears throat] got a menu. And
by the way, this is a known so this is a
known attack. Uh it's called stimpic. as
part of picop pona and when I published
the code um full credit to them is in
there. The difference here is uh we're
doing a non-deterministic hopefully
we're turning so I'm doing the opposite
of what Gaddy said we should all be
aiming for. Um so I'm trying to turn a
nondeterministic
process into a deterministic one. Um,
and we do that by letting the controller
uh or letting the Pico do the whole
process. So to just explain what it's
going to do,
it's going to connect over SWD. It's
going to load a payload into flash.
It's then going to reboot.
Uh, it's going to cause a brown out that
basically causes the chip to reboot. Um,
but the brownout isn't going to go low
enough to to wipe the flash. So, the
code I want to run will survive the
glitch. And then stage two, it will come
in. it reconfigures the um the memory
mapper to think that the flash is the
SRAMM
and then it'll do another glitch which
will cause it to boot off the flash
which the chip thinks is SRAM uh sorry
other way around SRAMM which the chip
thinks is flash and because it booted
off flash you have read access to the
flash you can dump the memory Here
he goes.
Have we sacrificed enough kittens this
morning for the demo gods to love me?
Boobies.
I have two minutes left. I think that's
questions, right? Or is the questions
after the Okay. So, so I'll just show
you one more thing.
So, basically, I told it to just give me
a lot of tooling so I can understand
what's happening. So if I run the R
command,
this is doing the initial sweep
to understand at what point SRAMM
survives, but the brownout trigger kicks
in and causes a reset. Uh, so it's going
to keep going down until SRAMM gets
corrupted and then we'll get a nice
little table.
So yeah, talk amongst yourselves.
If anyone's got a question, you can
shout it out now because this will take
about another 20 seconds.
>> Oh, done. Okay.
So, yeah, as you can see, what we have
now is
the NRST is the reset flag. So, it's
like a reverse um
pin that tells me that it it triggered
and it's now in in not reset mode. So,
um this window down here between 161
and 089 is a really big window where I
can achieve what I want. I caused a
reset, but I haven't lost the contents
of flash. And it gives you timing. So if
you want to do it the oldfashioned way,
you know, how the kids used to do it in
the old days with timing. I mean, so
yesterday. Um, but yeah, there you go.
That's it.
I have to imagine there will be
questions just after we take like three
seconds for this to integrate. Uh, yeah,
questions.
So if you're interested, take a picture
of that URL. That's the framework. It's
already published. It does not have this
code in it yet. I need to backport it
into there, but I'll do that probably in
the next week. So, but the main
framework is there. It's already useful
for other stuff as well. So
>> Adam, I'm curious if in the the first
time you used it to do the glitch and
then it worked the first time right
away. Uh did you actually ask it to
explain why it picked those particular
parameters?
>> Yeah. So the uh which is even more
amazing. Um
basically I told it in the dialogue
about setting the three question
answers. Um,
I said, I've got a flash dump of the
bootloadader because you can read out
the bootloadader
um from static uh memory.
And so it reverse engineered it and
counted the steps between. So it said,
well, the obvious target is you send a
read command for the memory. And it then
counted the steps between receiving the
car or echoing the carriage return of
the read and doing the compare to the uh
lock key and it it then said okay it's
it's running on this chip at this number
of megahertz so it'll be this number of
microsconds
as it happens the window was pretty big
so I could just do it at zero but I've
also used the same so I use the JTAG
interface
um to single step. So you can get even
more accurate that way. So you put a
break point where you want to stop and
then you tell it to single step to that
break point.
>> We've got one more. We got one one more
question back. Sorry.
>> So you use Claude to help you that first
time around and he gave you a really
good answer. Have you baked in any of
your knowledge into that? Over here.
>> Sorry, I'm being stupid. I can't see who
was asking.
>> Over here. It's cool. Yeah. So, have you
had have you done any more baking of
your knowledge of how to do stuff into
it since you've got the one good answer
from it that original time?
>> Oh, yeah. Since then, so that was in
October. Um, since then, every kind of
spare minute between doing my real day
job and well, actually incorporating
this into our work processes is now also
my real day job. Actually, my colleague
is doing a phenomenal job and it's kind
of embarrassing what I'm showing here
compared to what he's now done with it.
Um, but yes, I'm constantly trying
different targets, training it on
processes that the Raiden mentioned in
the name Raiden Pico is a project me and
a colleague wrote at IBM when I was at
X-Force and it took us over a year, two
of us working on it full-time.
Um Claude rewrote it in 3 days. So
>> uh I'm very curious like uh have you
tried using cloud to rev some like other
devices and like uh not pickle but
something else and and also like what do
you feel like would be like the
difference of like uh hacking pickle and
other devices?
>> Um so to use it on another device the
the reason I chose the pico is because
it's cheap. So, they're like seven bucks
or something. Um, the
the equipment in that first picture that
is replaced by the Pico is over $1,000
worth of equipment. And the Pico is
performing every single function of
every one of those components. So, my
idea was it becomes disposable. You can
take your $7 Pico and wire it in. I've
I've spoken at length, you know, in that
first picture there was all these cables
and crap everywhere. Um I've spoken
before about that what I call spaghetti
is your enemy in in glitching. So with
this system, you can actually solder the
Pico directly into a test circuit and
it's disposable. You don't care if if
you burned a pico. It's like seven
bucks. So, but yes, you could port it to
something else if you want to start
attacking mezz or giga or gigahertz
speed platforms. Maybe you want to go to
a Raspberry Pi 5. But you can just say
to Claude, port this code to there.
Probably in an hour max, you'll have it
working. So, yeah, go for it.
>> So, I would like to step in for a couple
minutes to tell you a few things this
guy did not tell you. He gave me way too
much credit. Trust me, he did everything
on his own. I never even touched
hardware in my life. But a couple of
points that are really critical. I think
one my f the first Defcon talk I ever
went to that I remember probably defcon
13. I don't remember maybe 14. Major
went on stage [clears throat]
and told people how he played with
magnetic cards to the degree where he
got magnetic gel to try and see where
the lines are. And you saw like 64-bit
security and then you saw the only the
first four bits or five bits change and
the sixth one gives everybody must
master or whatever it is and the hotel
in Vegas sent their security after him
for trying too many things their IDs
played up and he's been there for every
stage of hardware hacking for I don't
know how many years whether it's those
keys that they start thinking about uh
special forces using or RFID and
whenever there is something out there
that is hardware hacking you can always
find a major conversation, a major major
talk somewhere before somebody publishes
the big frameworks. And
this time is no different. He's been
helping a lot of people get into
hardware hacking. He has groups. And
what people need to understand, what
you've just seen is not just cool. It's
just one small aspect of the world
that's completely changed and we don't
even see. And I would like to tell you
three reasons why. I don't even know if
it's really three. I was in the
military. I just say three. We'll figure
it out. We'll figure it out as it goes
as we go. Number one, glitching is cool.
I don't know. I could spend like so many
years in security and not know it
exists, at least in that name. But it's
way cool, but it's also hard. He told
you he spent like six weeks as he was
going home. He was traveling. He came
back. The system still worked. I mean,
how did that happen? No success. You
judging he literally messaged me and
said, "Do you remember that talk from
promp to get the [\h__\h] out where somebody
did some reversing? I said you're here.
Do you remember that talk when they used
multiple here?" and he comes back and he
says, "Yeah, three attempts on chip and
I succeeded." And that's level one.
Here's number two. Number two is now
says, "Now that I have this capability,
I'm suddenly programming the next layer,
which is true for all of us. Glitching
has been something you had to work hard
with hardware. It works now. This guy,
it doesn't tell you the impact,
literally says, I can program next
layer." I'm not sure what that means
yet, but I'm imagining it's not just
about let's try and find the right
location with the right angle and the
right timing for the pulse to find that
CMP instruction and flip it, right? It's
about can I do two in a row? Can I try
and change the timing somehow? This guy
essentially is constantly finding the
next layer and the next layer. So for
me, it's not about the frontier
foundation models, labs, PhD people.
It's about the power users who keep
learning, keep trying, who say they
don't know [\h__\h] who go and try things
and again go to the next layer and the
next layer they are making the
difference and that's a difference we
can all make. Going off my soap box,
there's number three.
Glitching is a hobbyist's expensive
job hobby role or it's a nation states.
I imagine there are multiple nation
states all around the world still even
though we have eim now trying to bypass
SIM cards or credit cards a lot of crazy
[\h__\h] that's been going through a lot of
hardening for many many years and what
this guy here just showed you is that it
doesn't take a lab anymore you have this
pico here although you still need a lab
to do more than that all it takes is
working with blood code being a little
bit smart understanding a little bit and
the nation state level capability just
became something everybody can
and do it 10 times better. And that is
something that we're also con constantly
going to see whether it's in social
engineering becoming psychological
profiling or whether it's about coding
or whatever it is. So now I can get off
my soap box and say this guy here did
not want to come speak. This guy here
never puts himself forward but he just
in a minor huge way changed the world
and made hardware hacking accessible to
everybody. Thank you for all you do.
Thank you.